icon now I'm a big time fan since 1998.
oh wow I'm 38 now so most of my life uh
so cool I missed the uh if they made it
bits but um I watched that I forgot
about this you miss a bit that I no
longer remember that's really sweet I do
meet people we did a bit like in 1994
called pimp bot he was half robot pimp
and we did it for like a year or two and
it has a fanatical following and every
now and then to this day I'll meet like
a 55 year old man who's like pimp bot
where is is he where's pimpai what's
your pie it's like a guy who doesn't
know the war is over 100 years later so
how can I help you sir so uh I watched
the hour-long special on how you got
late night and I wanted to know after
those first early tenuous years when did
you realize that you were good and kind
of gained some content um well uh
uh it took a super long time to be
honest with you and it's funny because
um I remembered a young person they had
a bunch of college students come in just
a few years ago when we were doing the
show over at Warner Brothers the Conan
show and she said when does the
nervousness and self-doubt end and I
said I have really bad news for you
there's always some of that you know so
yeah we had kind of a
um interesting introduction to late
night television uh it was at the time a
really big deal that an unknown person
was getting this show and so I kind of
had to learn how to do the job in front
of everybody and man uh people had very
strong opinions
um many of them negative but uh young
people really liked it and I think that
that was nice but I didn't know that I
was not aware of that and I only found
out about it until much later on when
those young people grew up into
and became really successful Comedians
and they would say oh your show we used
to watch a show all the time that was
the show we really loved and I was like
why didn't you tell me
why John Mulaney why didn't you tell me
he was like I was nine why would why
would you have listened to a
nine-year-old and I said I would have
listened to anybody
I would have been so happy so it took a
while it took a it took a number of
years and um to just you know and
insecurity and all those things that
that people uh have and I just like to
be really honest about the fact that it
never
quite goes away you're always
hoping is this good enough was that okay
could this be better I mean it goes back
to I know it sounds like I was doing a
bit yelling at myself in the mirror uh
at three o'clock in the morning uh but
that still happens uh it doesn't go on
too long because my wife's not having it
uh but
um yeah there's uh
some unhealthy elements probably that
that uh go into doing this day in and
day out and wanting it to be you know
special or good uh and I think trying to
figure all that out has taken me a long
time but
um marrying the right person really
helped having great kids uh uh helped
and you know getting some help really
helped I'm very vocal about that I think
people should uh
um not you know should be very open to
talk therapy uh if they need it and if
they do it responsibly you know getting
on meds stuff like that I think that has
made a huge a huge difference in my life
so but it took a while it took a long
time